you
this is Dominic Dominic works at a
5-star restaurant called the pixel
palace they're some of videogames most
popular characters come in to have a
drink sometimes they share stories and
even secrets for as we all know what the
bartender hears is confidential isn't it
some sit there tending bar when in walks
on our turn see they often fox mccloud
now of course he's part of the starfox
true so he goes on missions very often
but once in a while he does drop by the
actual bomb but that's always been sort
of this mystery to him you know not too
many people know much about him so I
decided I'm gonna find out a little bit
more about him so I serve in his drink
and I asked him a mr. McCloud what you
been up to and he says oh but going
through some real personal discoveries
so really imagine someone going through
a personal discovery here at the pizza
palace so I asked him I said what about
nice as well just sort of what I like
what I don't like so many mates as well
it's hard to explain but um I think sort
of a change you know
species
like a species change it goes no no no
not quite like that I'm not going
through any operations I mean lord knows
we all know that kara table used to be
an orangutan I'm not doing anything like
that and I'll say what were you talking
about that legs as well recently I've
just had this real fascination with
humans
okay I guess that's not too bad I mean
how do you mean passivation it says I
don't know just something about the how
soft they are the size of their eyes the
way that design everything about just
this strange fascination with them
I said
are you a human e and he says yes that's
exactly what I am i human e someone who
has a fascination with human life-forms
and I said oh oh okay e so um so you
like to get it on with people their
faces that is a stereotype absolutely
not true
sure there's some animals out there I
like to get on with people but it is a
stereotype that human needs are a part
of that and I said look mr. MacLeod
there should be any shame in it flow
Shabo flow showboaters how you're born
eight says no has nothing to do with it
I'm not that kind of person
I said okay what does a human e do then
I said well the main thing that human
E's like to do is we like to dress
unlike humans you know the lowercase
human is just sort of talk in their
tales or wear human ears on the side of
the heads but the higher class human
ease they take it a step further you say
they actually get masks even full-on
Bali's suits that just come of their
entire body totally furless nice and Wow
I said well what kind of humans do you
dress up as they says well if you won't
go real easy you go for Ken you know I
can it Bobby cuz you know here razón
looks plastic if you want to get a
little more complicated you go for a
puppet like Howdy Doody or any of the
main characters from called sprite you
see the more smooth and plasticky it is
the more popular it is it's all about
having no further there's any Fernet we
want it gone that's it okay well what do
you go dressed as
since I do dressed as Jessica Rabbit
sort of a cross you minee everywhere and
he let's face it she doesn't exist so
she'll read sort of looks smooth and
plasticky already and I said although yo
you're dressing up as Jessica Rabbit
makes it yeah
I'll something there's no sexual issues
with this at all I says no are you sure
because it sounds like there's some sort
of sexual undertone going on the
electors nope not at all I just want the
dress
I'll said okay as long as you sure well
what else do you you and ease do face as
well we like to get together and play
games and talk to one another make jokes
sodomized one another then usually go
out and have a bit of denies at home
hold on was the middle part except
though we like to go out to dinner I
said Nana no before that it's a toe we
told a wise each other
okay
that is sex that is set this is a sexual
thing and it's a notice and I said yes
it is you just said you have sex with
other people
asset that makes it a sexual thing
it says no doesn't I said why not basic
as won't cost you it's all other
identity Stuart not us doing it
therefore it's okay and I'll sit look
I'm sure that's human ease out there
that enjoy being a human e without doing
anything sexual with her there's no
sexual connection but you are not one of
those people you clearly have some
issues and he said look if I want to get
dressed up as Catwoman every other night
and get it on with another human
interest as Batman that's my prerogative
but it's not a sexual thing just because
there's sex in it doesn't make it a
sexual thing I said I think that's the
definition of it's a sexual thing he
said no it's not arson okay whatever
works for you mate so we sat down silent
for a little bit not saying a word to
each other and then I decided to bring
up two awesome you know
people have something Thanks similar to
what you're talking about
it says woody Lee I said what I don't
know it's always a sexual thing it says
it's not essential valid okay okay Hausa
but there are people who have a real
fascination for dressing up as animals
and they on back home Burmese
who is drink in my face and tell me to
piss off and that's the last I ever saw
of him having interesting psyche that
one has about the same self-esteem as
only well since : as far but it's not
normally used to say the only thing
worse than not knowing it's knowing my
mothers are very that as why I bet you
see a wall of strange things as a
bartender see your model strange things
at the picture Palace so I'll see a lot
of strange things as a bartender at the
pixel palace and that ain't no I swear